CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA
ATKINS BATES WELL FORAGES
BRADFORD CABALLERO CHIANG DALLY
DODD THE RAZA GALGIANI GONZALEZ
ROSE HERTZBERG HILL HUESO TADO
JACKSON JONES. LEYVA MCGUIRE
MELENDEZ MITCHELL MINING
MORLOCK NIELSEN PAN PORTANTINO
ROTH. RUBIO SKINNER STERN
AMBERG BY CAL SKI WIENER WILK.
COLLEAGUES SAY QUORUM IS
PRESENT MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE A
SENATOR GLAZERS AND SENATOR
MORALE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY I
DON'T SEE SENATOR MARIAL HERE
BUT SENATOR GLAZER IS AND
WELCOME. THE SENATORS WILL
PARTICIPATE IN DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE BUT WILL NOT BE
PARTICIPATING IN THE QUORUM
CALL OR THE VOTE ON MEASURES
AND WITH THAT WOULD THE MEMBERS
IN OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WE WILL BE LET PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY SENATOR PAM AFTER
PAGE PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE
WILL BE LEADING THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO. THANK YOU
SIR FOR THE PRAYER. PEACEFUL
BOND. PRESS OF ALL THAT IS ON
THE SOLEMN REMEMBRANCE OF THE
SEVENTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE BOMBINGS OF HIROSHIMA AND
NAGASAKI. WE CALL OURSELVES TO
SINCERE PURSUIT OF PEACE. AND
UNDERSTANDING THIS ALTERNATIVE
T. VIOLENT WAYS OF RESOLVING
CONFLICTS. FREAS THE LORD FROM
THE ZENO PHOBIC FEARS THAT
PREVENT US FROM SEEING THE
GOODNESS IN OTHERS. HELP US TO
BE ADVOCATES OF A WORLD FREE
FROM THREATS AND TURN OF
NUCLEAR WAR. LET US ACT ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN WHO
DEPEND ON US FOR THEIR SAFETY
AND SECURITY. MAYBE BE INSPIRED
BY THE HOPE AND TRUST OF
SEDUCTIVE WHENEVER TO MAKE A
THOUSAND PAPER CRANES BEFORE
SHE DIED. OF THE IMPACT OF THE
BOMBINGS. DALY BECOME PAPER
TRANSFER PLEASE EACH ONE
PROCLAIMING BY AIRLINES THE
WORDS UNSAID DOCTORS PEACEFUL
MORAL. THIS IS OUR PRIORITY
THIS IS A PRAYER. FOR THE
BUILDING OF PEACE IN THE WORLD.
EIGHTY NINE. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE SUCH
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR. THERE ARE IN THE NONE
OF OR I'M SORRY MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED TO
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
PURSUANT TO RULE SENATE RULE
TWENTY NINE TEN THE SUBDIVISION
D. THE FOLLOWING BILLS ARE
REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE. ITEM SIXTEEN SB SIX
EIGHTY FOUR. CAN SENATOR
MELENDEZ FOR WHAT PURPOSE. RISE
TO MAKE A MOTION PURSUANT TO
SENATE RLE TWENTY EIGHT TO
WITHDRAWAL IS C. R. NINETY
THREE FROM THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE AND BROUGHT TO THE
SENATE FLOOR SET THE FULL
SENATE CAN HAVE A VIGOROUS AND
ROBUST DEBATE ABOUT THE MERITS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S STATE OF
EMERGENCY. THANK YOU CENTER
MELENDEZ SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MAJORITY LEADER US FOR A NO
VOTE. RIGHT THIS IS NOT
DEBATABLE SENATOR JONES. THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS CHAIR ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE VERY GOOD.
SENATOR HERTZBERG AS FOR A NO
VOTE SENATOR JONES ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN NO
ARCHULETA NO ATKINS NO BATES. I
FELT KNOWN MORTON. FIVE
BRADFORD. BRADFORD NOTE. NO BY
ADAM. CHIANG. DALLY FIVE DOT.
NO TORONTO BLUE NOTE GALGIANI
NO GONZALEZ. NO GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG THERE WE GO NO HELLO
NO WAY SO. NO FURTADO NO
JACKSON NO NO JONES HI I LEYVA.
NOTE MCGUIRE. NO MELENDEZ HI
MITCHELL NO MONEY. NO MORE LOCK
HI NIELSEN. PAN NO NO
PORTANTINO. NO ROTH. HELLO
RUBIO. SKINNER I'M A BIT NO
STERN. NUMBER NO WHITE HOUSE
ECONOMIC. NO WE WHEN IN DOUBT
YOU KNOW WELL. HI THERE'S
ANOTHER THANK YOU THANK HIS
EIGHT NOS TWENTY FIVE THE
MOTION FAILS MOVING ALONG
COLLEGE I'VE BEEN TOLD THERE'S
A HOT MIKE SOMEWHERE. SO PLEASE
BE. AWARE OF THAT DURING YOUR
CONVERSATIONS. AND WITH THAT.
WE WILL GO TO CAN I'M SORRY
SENATOR PAM FOR WHAT PURPOSE
SIR THANK YOU UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION I
MOVED JOINT RULE SIXTY TO
EIGHTY WAIT FOR THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE HERE CERTAINLY BILL
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE ON MONDAY
AUGUST TENTH TWENTY TWENTY
WITHOUT FOUR DAYS NOTICE IN THE
DAILY FILE. THE OBJECTION I'M
SORRY SENATOR BROWN'S SORRY
MADAM PRESIDENT- WE DO OBJECT
AND ASK FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE IN
THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS CHAIR
ASKS FOR NOVA VERY GOOD SENATOR
PAN OF SENATOR HERTZBERG.
SECOND WORK. OKAY ALL RIGHT
THERE IS A AN OBJECTION.
SENATOR PAN S. FOR AN AYE VOTE
THE SENATOR JONES S. FOR NO
VOTE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES NO
BELL HI BORJAS NO BRADFORD I
HAVE A- I CHIANG. DALLY. NO
DODD. I DRAWS THEM. I GALGIANI
AYE GONZALEZ I GROWH. GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO.
I HER TADO. FIVE JACKSON HI
FIVE JONES. NO LEYVA. FIVE
MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING. HI
MORLOCK NO NIELSEN. PAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. FIVE RUBIO.
SKINNER FIVE STERN NUMBER HI I
Y. CASKEY HI WIENER. HI WILK.
NO I TWENTY SIX KNOWS EIGHT THE
MOTION PASSES WITHOUT WE WILL
MOVE ON TO. I'M SORRY SENATOR
HERTZBERG FOR WHAT PURPOSE ARE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
EMOTIONS RESOLUTIONS I MOVE
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO EIGHT BE
WAIVED FOR THE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE TO HEAR
ASSEMBLY BILLS SEVENTY AND
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY THREE ON
SATURDAY AUGUST EIGHTH TWENTY
TWENTY WITHOUT FORTY NOTICE IN
THE DAILY FILE. THANK YOU
SENATOR HERTZBERG SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT WE
ALSO OBJECT TO THIS MOTION I
WOULD AK FOR ALL CALL VOTE BUT
IF THERE IS NO OBJECTION- WE
WOULD ACCEPT THE- PRIOR ROLL
CALL. IN PLACE FOR THIS
OBJECTION. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT WILL BE THE ORDER. HIS
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS EIGHT.
EXCUSE ME IS TWENTY SIX KNOWS
EIGHT THE MOTION PASSES. RIGHT
SEEING NO OTHER MICROPHONES UP
AT THIS POINT IN TIME WE WILL
PROCEED WITH THE CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE AND WITH THAT
WE ARE AT THE SECOND READING
FILE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED WITH AMENDMENTS
TEN SEVENTY ONE WITH AMENDMENTS
AND ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY
SIX WITH AMENDMENTS SECOND
READING FILE HAS BEEN COMPLETED
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. SENATOR
MORALE FOR WHAT PURPOSE SIR.
SENATOR MORALE THE FLOOR'S
YOURS. NO I PUT HAVE COLLEGE AS
I WAS JUST CHECKING IN BECAUSE
I KNEW YOU GUYS WERE LOOKING
FOR ME EARLIER SO. THAT THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN TAKE CARE OF. WE
DO SEE YOU. THANK YOU AYE. I
SEE YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
INDEED UNDER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS FILE ITEM SEVEN
SENATOR WILK. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROCEED. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF WINDY STRAPPED
TO THE BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES THREE SILVERADO AND
MATTHEW SWANSON TO THE
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION
ROBINSON KICKED SOME KEYS TO
THE COURT REPORTERS BOARD AND
DERRICK MAY TOAST AND CHRISTY
TRAN TO THE BOARD OF BARBER
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY ALL
THESE APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON THE
FIRST OF JULY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THE APPOINTMENT
SENATOR JONES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- THERE'S A- FEW
CONCERNS WITH THE NOMINEES. BUT
I DID WANT TO ADDRESS A
PARTICULAR ISSUE REGARDING THE-
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY
BOARD. I'M HOPING THAT THESE
NOMINEES WILL. TAKE A POSITIVE
ATTITUDE TOWARDS THE BARBERING
COMMUNITY AND- MAYBE CURTAIL
SOME OF THE GOVERNOR'S ACTIONS
THAT HE'S USING THROUGH THIS
BOARD. AND GOING AFTER OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE TRYING TO
MAKE AN HONEST LIVING BY BEING
A BARBER OR COSMETOLOGIST OR
NAIL SALON- OR WHATEVER- OTHER.
BUSINESSES THAT THIS BOARD
REGULATES AND LET OUR
CONSTITUENTS DO THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE TRAINED TO DO. THERE
ARE SOME OF THE SAFEST-
OCCUPATIONS IN THE STATE THEY
HAVE BEEN SANITIZING AND
KEEPING THEIR CUSTOMERS SAFE
EVEN BEFORE COLVIN NINETEEN
STARTED AND SO I JUST WANTED
TO- IN COURAGE THESE NOMINEES
AT TO DO THAT THE RIGHT THING
FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS THANK YOU.
THE JOURNEY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THE NOMINEES
PLEASE ON THE NOMINEES. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SENATOR WILK
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ALL FOR DEBATE
HAVING SEIZED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS. AYE
BATES I TELL HI GORGEOUS I
BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM HI
CHIANG HI DALLY. DODD. FIVE
TERRAZZO HI HI GALGIANI HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I HERTZBERG
HI HILL HI HI HUESO. HI HER
TADO FIVE JACKSON HI I JONES. I
LEYVA I MCGUIRE FIVE MELENDEZ.
MITCHELL FIVE MONNING FIVE
MORLOCK HI NIELSEN. PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO HI ROTH. FIVE RUBIO
HI SKINNER. HI STERN AMBERG HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI. HI WIENER HI
WILK I. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. DALLY HI.
MELENDEZ I NIELSEN STERN. HIGHS
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED
MOVING ALONG NOW TO FILE ITEM
EIGHT SENATOR WILK THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER IS A CONFIRMATION OF
CAROL BAKER FOR REAPPOINTMENT
TO THE CALIFORNIA WATER
COMMISSION MISS BAKER WAS FIRST
APPOINTED TO THE BOARD IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN SHE PREVIOUSLY
SERVED THE SPEAKS OFFICE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS THE CHIEF POLICY
FOR NATIONAL RESOURCES IN
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION IN ITS
DEPUTY BUDGET DIRECTOR SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES EIGHTY ON
JULY FIRST AT RISK WE ASK. AND
I. PETER DOES CENTERED
HERTZBERG. STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF CAROL BAKER I WAS A
SUCCESSFUL I SHOULD SAY DIANNE
GRIFFITHS WAS SUCCESSFUL IN
PERSUADING HER TO LEAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND JOIN.
US IN THE LEGISLATIVE SHOULD
GOVERNMENT MANY YEARS AGO AND
SHE SERVED WITH EXTRAORDINARY
ENERGY IT DISTINCTION
INTELLIGENCE AND- JUST ONE OF
THE BEST PEOPLE I KNOW A STRAND
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF DRUG BAKER.
THANK YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG. SO
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
ALTHOUGH I AGREE THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS THE RIGHT TO
CHOOSE IS ON THESE PARTICULAR
WORDS- MISS BAKER HAS SERVED ON
THE WATERBOARDING THE PAST INTO
GOVERNOR BROWN SHE ACTUALLY-
FIXED A VOTE NOT SIXTY BUT TO
ALLOCATED AND STOP TO VOTE.
STARTED A VOTER HAD OF WHAT
HAPPENED SO THAT TEMPERANCE
FLAT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
COULDN'T BE FUNDED IT COST A
LOT OF FARMERS AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WATER TO BE ABLE TO FEED
YOUR KIDS. AND SO. THAT MISS
BAKER A BOARD. APPOINT A BY
THIS GOVERNOR I THINK IS NOT
GOOD FOR ANYBODY SEEN THAT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY A HAS THE TOP
THREE AGRICULTURE PRODUCING.
COUNTIES IN THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE FOOD IS
PRODUCED FOR ALL OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IN TEMPERATE
SUPPLIES IMPORTANT AND- WE NEED
THAT WATER IN THE CENTER VALLEY
TO CONTINUE TO GROW FOOD TO PUT
ON THE GROCERY SHELVES. SO THE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE FOOD TO EAT
FAMILIES THE WORD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NO. THANK YOU SENATOR
DOLLY IS YOUR MICROPHONE UP.
ALL RIGHT KIND OF HARD TO.
FIGURE THAT OUT ALL RIGHT VERY
GOOD- ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS APPOINTMENT
CHING IN HEARING ON SENATOR
WILK WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESHAPE THE COMMENTS FROM ALL
THE SENATORS AND- VOTE. ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND FILE ITEM EIGHT. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS I BATES NO
BELL FIVE GORGEOUS NO BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO I CHIANG. DALLY
NO DODD FIVE TO RAZA. HI
GALGIANI. HI GONZALEZ HIGH
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. HI HILL
AYE HUESO. HI HURTADO HI
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA. FIVE
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL
I MONNING. I MORE LOCK NO
NIELSEN PAN I PORTANTINO. HI
ROTH I RUBIO HI SKINNER I
STERN- BURKE HI WHY CASKEY HI
WIENER HI WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. CHIANG NIELSEN.
STERN WILK. IS TWENTY SEVEN NO
SEVEN THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NINE SENATOR WILK. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE IS A CONFIRMATION
OF KIMBERLY MAKORI WAIT AS
DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF AGING
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT MR
MCCOY WADE WAS CALFRESH
NUTRITION BRANCH CHIEF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES SHE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON THE
TWENTY NINTH TO JULY RESPECT WE
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR WILL CONSIDER ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
APPOINTMENT. ANY DEBATE SENATOR
PAM FLOOR'S YOURS MADAM
PRESIDENT- I STAND SUPPORT OF
SLATED FOR DIRECT AGING THIS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT POSITION-
AS- INTERACTING WITH THE- AGING
WE THE GOVERNOR DID SET SOME
AMBITIOUS GOALS FOR AGING IN
TERMS OF A- TASK FORCE TO LOOK
AT AGING. EVEN WITH COLLUDED I
HOPE THAT THAT WORK WELL TO.
UNABATED WE OBVIOUSLY KNOW THAT
LEFTOVER COMPLIMENT IT IS TO
ADDRESS ISSUES OF AGING.
INCLUDING THE FACT THAT THERE
THIS POPULATIONS MOST
VULNERABLE AND I CERTAINLY
BELIEVE IN HOPE AND CONFIDENCE
IN THIS WAY CAN. BE ANSWERED AT
THIS. ISSUED A WILL CONTINUE ON
A- DESPITE OVER NINETY AND SO I
STANDS THANK YOU. THANK SENATOR
PENNY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SEEING AND HEARING
NON. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ACTIONS FIVE BATES
AYE BELL AYE BARGES AYE
BRADFORD. I HAVE A HI CHIANG HI
DOLLY FIVE DODD. FIVE DURAZO HI
JOHNNY HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO. JACKSON HI I JONES
FIVE LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ AYE MITCHELL. HI
MINING FIVE MORLOCK. I NIELSEN.
PAN I PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER. FIVE STERN.
NUMBER FIVE WHAT CASTING AYE
WIENER FIVE WELL. FIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE
MORE TIME. HURTADO I NIELSEN
STERN ALL EYES THIRTY SIX KNOWS
ZERO THAT APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. MOVING ON NOW TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS WORD FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN. FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN. CENTER I'M BURGER
ARE YOU PREPARED TO PROCEED I
AM ALL RIGHT VERY WELL THEN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOR TWENTY THREE BY
SENATOR UMBERG AND ACTUALLY IN
TWO ELECTIONS AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY PARASITIC EFFECT
MEDIALLY SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS-
THIS NOVEMBER WILL HAVE THE
MOST ON YOU LECTURE AT LEAST IN
MY LIFETIME. BUT THERE WILL BE
AN ELECTION. AND IN ORDER TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THERE'S AS
MUCH ACCESS AS POSSIBLE WE
BRING YOU SB FOUR TWENTY THREE-
EVERY REGISTERED VOTER WHO'S
ACTIVE IN CALIFORNIA WILL
RECEIVE A BALLOT IN THE MAIL.
BY PROVIDING IT. THE PERSON. WE
AMENDED SB FOUR TWENTY THREE IN
THE ASSEMBLY GUARANTEE THEY'LL
BE ACCESSIBLE SECURE AND SAFE
IN PERSON OPPORTUNITIES FOR
VOTERS WHO CANNOT. OR CHOOSE
NOT TO USE THEIR VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT FOR FOUR FOUR FULL DAYS
STARTING THE SATURDAY PRIOR TO
THE ELECTION. SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE WILL REQUIRE NUMEROUS
CONVENIENT LOCATIONS FOR VOTERS
TO SIMPLY WAIT TO DROP OFF
THEIR BALLOTS AS WELL AS A
STATEWIDE VOTER EDUCATION. AND
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN. UP THERE
WILL BE A NECESSITY FOR IN
PERSON VOTING LOCATIONS BECAUSE
SOME FOLKS LOSE THEIR BALLOTS.
SOME FOLKS- THE BALLOTS ARE
DESTROYED IN SOME FASHION. OR
THEY MAY NEED ASSISTANCE
BECAUSE OF SOME PERSONAL
CHALLENGE- THE COUNTIES HAVE AN
OPTION TO. OPT IN OR NOT OFTEN
THEY CAN CONDUCT THE ELECTION
AS THEY HAVE IN THE PAST BUT
NEVERTHELESS EVERY REGISTERED
ACTIVE VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA IS
GOING TO RECEIVE A BALLOT- THIS
IS A MEASURE ENSURES THAT IS
MANY MORE QUALIFIED TO VOTE.
CAN VOTE CAL VIRGIN ISLANDS.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SENATOR MORLOCK. THANK YOU
MATTER PRESIDENT- JUST A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR PLEASE
WOULD YOU TAKE A QUESTION
SENATOR ON BERKSHIRE HAPPY TO
I'VE I'VE- FOR TEN DAYS OVER
THREE SO I GUESS I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS YOU'D MENTIONED THAT
IT WOULD BE AN OPT IN FOR EACH
OF THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. SO
CERTAIN COUNTIES COULD STILL
STAY AT TEN DAYS. AND I'M JUST
CURIOUS. QUESTION TO THE LOGIC
FOR REDUCING IT TO THREE DAYS
SO- TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION YES
COUNTIES CAN OPT IN OF A COUNTY
REGISTER WHICH IS THEY HAVE A
POLLING PLACE OPEN FOR LONGER
THAN FOUR DAYS THEY CAN DO SO-
THE LOCK IS. IT IS IT IS A
COMPROMISE IN LIGHT OF THE FACT
THAT EVERYONE IS GOING TO GET A
MAIL IN BALLOT EVERYONE IS
ACTIVE REGISTERED IT'S GOING TO
GET IT ELLEN BACK- WE SAW IN
THE LAST ELECTION THE VOTING
CENTERS ARE FOR TEN OR ELEVEN
DAYS DID NOT SEE AS MUCH
ACTIVITY. IS ANTICIPATED. BUT
THERE WAS SIGNIFICANT. THE
SATURDAY TILL TWO. SO THAT'S
THAT'S WHY THAT'S WHY THIS
BILL. REQUIRES A BOATSWAIN'S BE
OPEN FOR AT LEAST FOUR DAYS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK
YOU THE SENATOR FROM ORANGE
COUNTY. GOOD THIS ANY FURTHER
DEBATER DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
SEEING NONE CENTER UNDER WHICH
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE URGENT AYE VOTE. ALL
DEBATE HAVING CEASED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BELL FIVE BORJAS.
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHANG
AYE DALLY. DODD I DRAWS THEM I
GALGIANI I GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG FIVE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI FURTADO HI JACKSON HI I
JONES. LEYVA HI MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ NO MITCHELL. HI
MONNING HI MORLOCK NIELSEN. PAN
I PORTANTINO. HI ROTH HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER. FIVE STERN I'M
BURKE HI WHAT KIND OF SKI FIVE
WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONE MORE TIME. BATES FOR JUST.
DALLY NO GROWTH NO JONES. NO
MORLOCK. NIELSEN STERN. HIS
TWENTY NINE KNOWS FOR ON THE
URGENCY IS TWENTY NINE KNOWS
FOR ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN COLLEAGUES IF I
COULD REMIND CHIU TO PLEASE
HAVE YOUR MASKS OVER YOUR NOSE
AS WELL MOST OF YOU ARE DOING A
GREAT JOB- BUT- AS AN EXAMPLE
OF TO OUR CONSTITUENTS AND TO
OUR COMMUNITIES ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF WEARING THOSE
MASKS AND WEARING THEM
APPROPRIATELY- THAT IS A
REQUEST I THINK THAT TO. WITH
IT ALL TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY AND
WITH THAT- WE HAVE COMPLETED
THE DAILY FILE ITEMS LET'S MOVE
TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT SHOWS
THERE ARE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENT FOR SHIPMENT HOUSE.
SENATOR WINNER AT THE PROMPT
GREAT- THANK YOU I'M PRESIDENT
OF HOUSING COMMITTEE. THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING- AFTER SESSION AS SOON
AS THE- CHAMBER COMPLAINTS.
VERY GOOD ARE THERE ANY OTHER
ANNOUNCEMENTS COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS SEEING NONE. AND
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS.
SENATOR RECKONS THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THANK YOU WELL.
COLLEAGUES I LET ME JUST WRAP
UP BY MAKING A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS YOU KNOW THIS- WORK
WEEK HAS BEEN BUSY ARE AND OF
COURSE IT'S NOT YET DONE- WE
ARE HERE TODAY AND TOMORROW
CONDUCTING COMMITTEE WORK. YOU
KNOW AS THE PRO TEM I GET THE
UPDATES THE DOWNLOADS THE
FEELINGS LEFT OVER GOOD BAD SAD
FROM A HARD WEEK. WE HAVE THREE
WEEKS AND FOUR DAYS REMAINING
UNTIL THE END OF SESSION. HI AN
END OF SESSION IS ALWAYS A
DIFFICULT TIME I WE KNOW THAT.
AT THE CERTAINLY ARE ANXIOUS
DAYS AND MANY OF US ARE.
SURROUNDED BY ANXIOUS SOULS.
OUR CONSTITUENTS HAVE EVERY
REASON TO BE ANXIOUS AND THEY
LOOK TO US TO GIVE THEM A SENSE
THAT IT'S ALL GOING TO BE OKAY
AT SOME POINT. AS WE FINISH
SESSIONTODAY AND LOOK FORWARD
TO THE NEXT THREE WEEKS AND
FOUR DAYS. I JUST WANT TO.
REMIND US TO. BE A LITTLE BIT
GROUNDED TAKE A LITTLE SPACE
TAKE A BREATH WALK OUTSIDE. AND
GET SOME AIR- THESE DAYS ARE
HARDER. THAN THEY TYPICALLY ARE
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO'VE BEEN
AROUND A LONG TIME YOU KNOW
THAT'S TRUE THE END OF SEPT AND
HAS A CERTAIN DYNAMIC. ARE WE
CARE A GREAT DEAL ABOUT OUR
PLEDGE INSTALLATION WE HAVE HAD
TO WORK IN VERY. AS IF WE
DIDN'T THINK THE END OF SESSION
LAST YEAR WERE INTERESTING AND
DIFFICULT ENOUGH. WE ARE
CHALLENGED AGAIN BY THE
UNIVERSE WITH PIERCE SESSION
AND A PANDEMIC. I JUST WANT TO
REMIND US TO REFLECT THE
CALMNESS THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS
REALLY NEED RIGHT NOW WE NEED
IT BUT THEY NEED IT. AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT LEADERSHIP
REALLY REQUIRES I'D LIKE US TO
ASPIRE ODD TO THOSE THINGS IT
CAN BE FORGOTTEN IN A MOMENT IN
THE HEIGHT. OF WHAT WE ARE
ENGAGING IN IN THE COMMITTEES
AND THE WORK AND THAT- THAT WE
TAKE SO SERIOUSLY AS
LEGISLATORS THIS HONOR THAT WE
HAVE BEEN GIVEN BY OUR
CONSTITUENTS. CLOSE I JUST
WANTED YOU HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR SERVICE I
APPRECIATE YOUR DEDICATION YOUR
COMMITMENT YOUR DILIGENCE TO
THE WORK THAT YOU WERE DOING.
AND YOUR INSPIRED LEADERSHIP.
AND SO AS WE- EXIT TODAY WITH
WORK YET TO GO I JUST WANT US
TO. REMEMBER HOW MUCH WE
ACTUALLY LIKE AND ENJOY EACH
OTHER- BECAUSE IT IS TRUE. AND
I APPRECIATE YOU AND WITH THAT
MADAM PRESIDENT I. THE NEXT.
TEN UP FLOOR SESSION AFTER WE
FINISH COMMITTEES TODAY AND
TOMORROW. IS MONDAY AUGUST
TENTH TWENTY TWENTY AT TWO PM
BE SAFE BE WELL HAVE A GREAT
WEEKEND. THANK YOU MADAM PRO
TEM FOR THOSE KIND WORDS AND
IMPORTANT WORDS I HOPE EVERYONE
HAS A- GOOD WEEKEND WE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL ALL LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS IS RECEIVED AT THE
DESK AND WE WILL RECONVENE
MONDAY. AT TWO PM.